-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and now if you don't mind
we are gonna get to the news.
President Biden tested positive
today for the coronavirus.
Luckily, we've all been
keeping our distance.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
tested positive today
for the coronavirus.
So, for the next two weeks,
the country will be hosted
by Chelsea Handler!
[ Laughter ]
She'll do great.
She's a pro.
According to a poll
released yesterday,
President Biden's approval
rating has hit a record low 31%,
putting him below the critical
"yellow Starburst" benchmark.
[ Laughter ]
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
help a prime-time hearing
tonight
and offered a timeline of what
former President Trump did
at the White House
during the insurrection.
We tape early,
but I'm guessing...
watched TV?
[ Laughter ]
That's like finding out
what Joey Chestnut did
on Fourth of July.
Same thing that he always does.
Former Vice President Mike Pence
spoke yesterday
at a South Carolina church
and said that the best part
of no longer being in office
is that he gets to drive
his own car,
and he made it very clear
that he drives an automatic
because it's a sin
to drive stick.
[ Laughter ]
His words, not ours.
I mean...
Authorities in Spain this week
arrested two thieves
who allegedly stole
45 bottles of wine from a hotel
that were worth
nearly $2 million.
Even worse, they stole
the Toblerone from the minibar,
valued at $3 million.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the Mega Millions
lottery jackpot
hit $630 million this week
after there were no winners.
Whoever wins it this week
can take the jackpot
in installments,
a lump sum,
or premium unleaded.
[ Laughter ]
Ohh! [ Laughs ]
That was a monologue, everybody.
We hope you enjoyed it.
And man, oh, man,
we have a great show
for you tonight.